.
JOINING ME NOW ROB SMITH, FORMER
ARMY VETERAN HOST OF THE PODCAST
ROB SMITH IS PROBLEMATIC AND
AUTHOR OF ALWAYS A SOLDIER AND
ALSO JACK CARR FORMER NAVY SEAL
AND AUTHOR OF THE DEVIL'S HAND.
GENTLEMEN, THANKS BOTH OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
YOU BOTH SERVED.
YOU HAVE LED WITH MEN.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN COMBAT.
ROB, LET ME ASK YOU, IS THIS A
SYSTEMICALLY EXTREME PROBLEM WE
HAVE IN THE MILITARY TODAY.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S DEFINE WHAT
EXTREMISM REALLY IS, RIGHT?
SO IN 2009, AN ARMY MAJOR NAMED
NIDAL HASAN WENT IN FORT HOOD,
TEXAS, SHOT AND KILLED 13 OF HIS
FELLOW SOLDIERS AND INJURED 30
MORE.
NOW THAT IS THE DEADLIEST
TERRORIST ATTACK THAT HAS EVER
HAPPENED ON A U.S. BASE IN
HISTORY, RIGHT?
SO THIS IS A PERSON THAT WAS
RADICALIZED BY RADICAL ISLAMIC
TERRORISM.
THAT IS THE KIND OF EXTREMISM
THAT WE USED TO HAVE TO KEEP
KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR AND ROOT OUT
IN THE AMERICAN MILITARY.
NOW THE KIND OF EXTREMISM THAT
THEY'RE DEFINING RIGHT NOW
BISHOP IMPAIR SON AND PEOPLE
LIKE HIM, THIS IS NOT EXTREMISM.
THIS IS THE -- WHAT THEY ARE
USING TO SORT OF PURGE POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
WHAT THEY ARE DEFINING AS
EXTREMISM THE SORT OF PATRIOT
EXTREMISM, WHITE NATIONALISM,
WHATEVER, THIS IS NOTHING OF THE
SORT.
THESE ARE PRETTY MUCH MILK TOAST
CENTER RIGHT REPUBLICAN LEANING
PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE VOTED FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MAY HAVE VOTED FOR OTHER
REPUBLICANS, AND MAY HAVE SAID
AS MUCH ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SO THEY ARE ONLY USING THIS
RIGHT NOW TO PRETTY MUCH PURGE
THE MILITARY OF ANY POLITICAL
ENEMIES AND TO THEM, A POLITICAL
ENEMY IS ANYBODY WHO IS NOT A
LIBERAL OR ON THE LEFT.
>> Pete: YES.
>> TO ME, THAT'S DANGEROUS FOR
FREE SPEECH.
IT'S ALSO DANGEROUS FOR THE
SOLDIERS THAT ARE SERVING
BECAUSE THEY ARE OPEN TO THE
REAL KIND OF EXTREMISM THAT I
TOLD YOU ABOUT EARLIER.
>> Pete: EXACTLY RIGHT.
JACK, WERE YOU FAMILIAR WITH
MUCH OF THIS?
WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT KIND OF THE
WOKISM AND THE READING LIST AND
SOME OF THAT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
BISHOP GARRISON UNTIL WE STARTED
LOOKING INTO THIS, THESE WORKING
GROUPS, HOW FAR IT WILL GO.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU?
>> IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME TODAY.
BUT IN MY 20 YEARS IN NAVAL
SPECIAL WARFARE IF WE WERE
EXTREME ABOUT ANYTHING OR IF I
NOTICED ANY EXTREMISM IT WAS WE
WERE EXTREMELY FOCUSED ON THE
MISSION AND EXTREMELY FOCUSED ON
THE TASK AT HAND BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE OWED THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT WE OWED THE MISSION
THE GUYS TO OUR RIGHT AND LEFT.
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE EXTREME
ABOUT.
OF NOTHING ELSE.
AND REALLY THE JOB OF THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY IS TO PREPARE
FOR WAR.
>> Pete: YES.
>> SO WHEN WE GET CALLED TO GO
TO WAR, WE ARE READY AND THEN WE
GO AND WE EXECUTE THE COUNTRY'S
BUSINESS.
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT DETRACTS
FROM THAT MISSION THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE AT PLAY THERE,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> Pete: BUT, I MEAN, WHERE DOES
THIS MINDSET COME FROM, ROB,
THAT IF SOMEONE USES THE WRONG
GENDER PRONOUN THEY CAN'T HAVE
YOUR BACK IN A FIRE FIGHT?
NOBODY IS PERFECT.
EVERYBODY HAS DIFFERENT
POLITICAL VIEWS.
THE MILITARY HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
MELTING POT, TRULY OF PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT BACKGROUND, RICH,
POOR, BLACK, WHITE.
WHERE DOES THIS SUDDEN MINDSET
COME THAT THESE TYPES OF PEOPLE,
PATRIOTS OR PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORTED TRUMP, THEY GOT TO GO.
THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
>> WELL, WHERE IT COMES FROM IS,
FIRST OF ALL, LIKE I SAID, THEY
HAVE A RUSH TO DEFINE ALL OF
THEIR POLITICAL ENEMIES RIGHT
NOW AS EXTREMISTS.
LIKE I SAID DEFINING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, GENERAL
CONSERVATIVES, ET CETERA.
THIS ALSO COMES FROM THE FAR
LEFT WOKE STUFF IF YOU WANT TO
CALL IT THEORY PEOPLE ANY OF
THAT STUFF.
THE PROBLEM WITH A LOT OF THIS
STUFF IT ASCENDS TO POSITIONS OF
POWER AS OF RIGHT NOW WHAT WE
ARE SEEING WITH THIS BISHOP
GARRISON PERSON NOW HE IS
INFLUENCING POLICY IN THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY.
SO THIS IS WHERE ALL OF THIS
STUFF COMES FROM.
I DO SOME WORK LIKE I SAID WITH
TURNING POINT U.S.A. ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
IT ALL STARTS THERE.
BUT IT HONESTLY ENDS UP IN THE
HALLS OF CONGRESS AS WE HAVE
SEEN.
IT ENDS UP IN THE PENTAGON.
AND IT ENDS UP VERY, VERY, VERY
CLOSE TO POWER WHICH IS WHAT WE
ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
AND STUFF LIKE THIS WILL DESTROY
THE MILITARY FROM THE INSIDE OUT
IF IT IS NOT -- IF A LIGHT IS
SHOT SHONE UPON IT.
>> Pete: LET'S SAY THE WORKING
GROUP COMES OUT WITH A
RECOMMENDATION AND AT OR NEAR AS
EXTREME AS THE TYPES OF THINGS
HE HAS TALKED ABOUT.
IN WHAT WAY IS A GENERAL TODAY
ABLE TO REJECT THAT?
OR IS THE GENERAL CLASS
EFFECTIVELY GOING TO HAVE TO SAY
HEY, IF I DON'T ACCEPT IT WHOLE
CLOTH THEN I'M THE RACIST, SO I
BETTER DO IT?
>> WELL, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT WE SEE IN THE MILITARY IS
AS I'M SURE YOU SAW THAT WHEN
YOU HIT A CERTAIN RANK, THESE
GUYS SOMETIMES TURN INTO
POLITICIANS AND THEY ARE SIGNING
THE DEAL FOR RAYTHEON OR
WHATEVER ELSE IS, A BUD I DON'T
UNDERSTAND BOARD THAT GOT OUT OF
THE MILITARY A COUPLE YEARS
BEFORE.
THERE IS MILITARY THAT'S A REAL
THING THAT MILITARY INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX.
ASKING OUR SENIOR LEVEL LEADERS
WHO ARE ESSENTIALLY JUST
POLITICIANS IN UNIFORM TO STAND
UP TO THIS STUFF, THAT'S
EXPECTING TOO MUCH FROM THESE
PEOPLE.
AND IN THE EARLY 1960s, THE
TRUST IN THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT WAS AT AN ALL-TIME
HIGH.
IT'S STEADILY DETERIORATED SINCE
THEN BUT WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
MILITARY, TRUSTING THE MILITARY
STARTED VIETNAM AND ESPECIALLY
19 WILL 0 ON THE TRUST WAS THERE
AND WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IS
THE EROSION OF TRUST IN THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY.
JUST LIKE WE ARE SEEING IT WITH
SUPREME COURT-ISSUES WITH THE
SUPREME COURT.
BUT THAT IS, I THINK, WHAT THE
OTHER SIDE IS TRYING TO DO IS TO
ERODE THAT TRUST DISTRUSTED
INSTITUTION.
AND WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
VETTING PEOPLE BEFORE THEY COME
IN IT'S NOT JUST WHAT THEY LIKE.
YOUR INTERVIEW WITH LARA LOGAN
LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE
SURVEILLANCE STATE.
EVERYBODY SHOULD LISTEN TO THAT.
IT WAS AMAZING.
JUST WHAT YOU HOVER ABOVE, THEY
KNOW EXACTLY WHERE YOUR LEANINGS
LIE WITHOUT EVEN HAVING --
>> Pete: HOW HARROWING IS THAT
YOUR KID RIGHT NOW INTERESTED IN
POLITICS MAKES COMMENTS HERE AND
THERE WANTS TO JOIN THE MILITARY
AND THEY SAY SORRY, YOU LOOK
LIKE AN EXTREMIST TO ME, KID.
TWO COLLEGE.
IT'S AMAZING.
ROB SMITH, JACK CARR, W